Created by Jack Kirby and Stan Lee in 1963's
The X-Men #4, Wanda Maximoff, the Scarlet
Witch, has some of the strangest stories in
comics.
From her mechanical ex-husband to the many,
many retcons of who her father is, here are
things Marvel wants you to forget about the
Scarlet Witch.
What even is Chaos Magic?
Scarlet Witch started out as a mutant who
had "hex powers," which basically meant that
she could do anything that the writer wanted.
Beyond wearing all red, Wanda Maximoff really
wasn't much of a Scarlet Witch at all.
She wasn't even scarlet on her first cover
appearance.
She wasn't truly witchy until writer Steve
Englehart had her study magic under Agatha
Harkness — an actual witch — in 1974's
The Avengers #128.
Later stories would establish that she was
gifted at magic because Chthon, the Marvel
universe equivalent to Cthulhu, molded her
at birth to be the perfect vessel for his
physical form.
Add in later retcons involving chaos magic
and reality warping, and her powers have remained
as ambiguous today as they were when she first
appeared.
"Her thing is neuroelectric interfacing telekinesis
and mental manipulation."
"He's fast and she's weird."
Who's your daddy?
While Wanda and her brother Pietro are popularly
known as the children of Magneto, that hasn't
always been the case.
In 1974's Giant-Size Avengers #1, it's established
that they were the children of the Whizzer
and Miss America, superheroes from Marvel's
Golden Age.
Wanda learns that, years ago, the Whizzer
had brought his pregnant wife to Wundagore
Mountain, where she died after delivering
twins.
Notably, this delivery occurred under the
watchful eye of the High Evolutionary, a geneticist
obsessed with, as his name suggests, evolution.
Bova, a talking cow woman, delivered Wanda
and Pietro.
Because comics are weird.
This would be retconned in 1979's The Avengers
#185.
In this version, a pregnant woman named Magda
appears at Wundagore Mountain to deliver twins,
Pietro and Wanda.
After she disappears, the High Evolutionary
gives them away to a traveling Romani family,
the Maximoffs, who raises them until Wanda
and Pietro join Magneto shortly before X-Men
#4.
"When brought to our home by a midwife.
Her name was Bova.
A most wondrous creature, part-human, part-animal."
Seriously, who's your daddy?
Magneto was officially confirmed to be their
father in 1983's The Vision and Scarlet Witch
#4, finally answering the lingering question
of who Wanda's biological father was.
But that wasn't the end of it.
"We are not your natural parents."
"What are you saying?"
In 2014's AXIS, Wanda discovered that Magneto
wasn't actually her father.
Later, she discovered later that she and Pietro
weren't actually ever mutants at all, but
regular humans who had been experimented on
by the High Evolutionary at birth to create
superpowered siblings.
In this most recent retcon, Wanda's biological
family is currently settled to be the Maximoffs.
Coincidentally, that revelation happened right
around the time that Twentieth Century Fox
had established that they owned the film rights
to both Magneto and "mutants" as a concept
… but there's probably no connection.
Demon babies
For a while, Wanda was married to the "synthozoid"
Avenger, Vision.
They even managed to have twins together through
Wanda's magic.
Unfortunately, it turned out that while the
children technically existed, they only existed
while Wanda was actively thinking of them
The demonic villain Master Pandemonium
stole and absorbed the twins, giving him the
unintentionally hilarious visual of a man
with babies for arms.
It later turned out that the babies were pieces
of the demonic Mephisto's soul that had been
blasted off.
When Wanda wanted children, she unintentionally
siphoned off parts of Mephisto's broken souls
to create them.
Agatha Harkness was able to banish Mephisto
by erasing Wanda's memory of
ever having children, which, thanks to her
subconscious reality warping abilities, meant
that they stopped existing.
Problem solved, right?
Avengers: Disassembled
In the Avengers: Disassembled story arc, Scarlet
Witch hits her breaking point after the Wasp
accidently reminds her of her memory-wiped
children.
The psychotic break that follows features
her going on an incredibly violent rampage
against the Avengers.
Hawkeye doesn't survive, Vision is ripped
in half, Agatha Harkness is discovered as
a rotting corpse, and Scarlet Witch herself
gets put into the custody of Magneto until
she can get the help she needs.
Which is a whole lot of help.
House of M
Wanda's reality-warping powers and mental
break lead to the 2005 Marvel crossover event
House of M, in which Wanda was coerced into
rewriting reality so that mutants are the
dominant life form on the planet.
When confronted by the various heroes who
remembered the old world, Wanda responds to
the stress and guilt by erasing the mutant
genome, turning almost every mutant in the
world into a powerless human.
Talk about lashing out.
Brotherly love
In the alternate reality of The Ultimates
comic series, Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver's
co-dependent relationship was rewritten to
be almost explicitly romantic between the
twins.
Worse, in Ultimates 3, the Wasp even chides
Captain America for expressing his judgement
of their romance by telling him that his World
War II sense of morality is outdated in this
modern world.
Gross.
To Avengers: Infinity War and beyond
With all the storylines mentioned above, you
might be thinking that the Marvel Cinematic
Universe made the right decision to simplify
both her origin and her superpowers.
A Scarlet Witch not bound by constant family
revelations and a codependent brother has
a lot of story potential.
Still, we'll have to see how that changes
as Disney starts to incorporate Twentieth
Century Fox concepts with the planned merger.
Whether that means leaning into the magical
angle like Dr. Strange or reincorporating
her into the mutant world, just about anything
can happen.
"I can't control their fear.
Only my own."
Well, almost.
It is probably fair to assume that we won't
be seeing Bova the bovine midwife or Master
Pandemonium and his baby arms on the big screen
anytime soon.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!